Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Heute gibt's ein luxuriöses Schichtdessert von mir.
Ich wurde nämlich von Magnum gefragt, ob ich nicht mit deren neuester Eiskreation, nämlich dem Double Gold Caramel Billionaire, etwas Schönes zaubern möchte.
Das habe ich mir nicht zweimal sagen lassen, denn ich musste dafür noch nicht einmal dieses leckere Magnum Eis kaufen gehen.
Mein ganzer Tiefkühlschrank ist voll damit, fragt den Hamza!
[Hamza] M-hm!
[Kiki] Jeden Abend vorm Fernseher wird erstmal gegönnt!
Ich gucke dafür mal rein!
Ich weiß natürlich, was für Schichten da enthalten sind, aus was das Eis besteht,
aber ich muss mich jetzt einmal aufopfern und hier einmal reinbeißen
damit wir mal gemeinsam reingucken, was da drin ist und aus was das Schichtdessert dann besteht.
[Hamza] Oh Du Armee!
[Kiki] Jaaa!
[Kiki] Mmmmh!
[Kiki] Ich muss nochmal damit man besser gucken kann, ja?
[Hamza] Okay!
[Hamza] Dieses typische Knacken, ne? Wie in der Werbung! *lacht*
Also wir haben hier 2 ineinander verstrudelte Eissorten.
Die eine schmeckt nach Keks, die andere Nach Pekannuss.
Außen ist eine Hülle aus Salted Caramel
und hier - das hier ist goldene Karamell Schokolade mit Keksstückchen.
Ich hab mir für heute überlegt: Ich mache Shortbread selber,
dann machen wir Salted Caramel selber und anschließend noch eine schöne Creme und werden das dann schichten
und ich hole jetzt erstmal die Zutaten für mein Shortbread.
Der Teig für unser Shortbread geht super easy.
Ich nehme hier zimmerwarme Butter, Zucker, Vanilleextrakt, Salz und Mehl.
Beim Salz dürft ihr übrigens nicht sparen, ist eines der wichtigsten Zutaten im Shortbread.
Und ich mache es so, dass ich einfach alles mit den Händen verknete.
Den Teig gebe ich dann auf mein mit Backpapier ausgelegtes Backblech.
Erstmal mit den Händen formen, anschließend könnt ihr mit 'nem Nudelholz drüber.
Und wichtig ist, dass wir das wirklich nur so 2mm dick ausrollen.
Wir brauchen's gar nicht dicker, denn gleich wird das alles sowieso noch fein gemixt,
bzw. vielleicht auch grob, ich mach's mal ganz spontan.
Bei Shortbread gibt's halt normalerweise diese ganz klassischen Pünktchen.
Da würde man dann mit 'nem Zahnstocher rangehen und dann ein paar Mal einstechen
und auch die Kekse dann schon zurechtschneiden.
Das entfällt hier alles weil es wird ja ein Schichtdessert.
Wichtig: Das kommt jetzt für 30min in den Kühlschrank - das ist super wichtig -
und anschließend in den vorgeheizten Backofen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
für ca. 8-10min bis es schön hell goldbraun ist.
Wir machen in der Zwischenzeit Salted Caramel selber, das geht auch wirklich ganz einfach.
Ich schreibe euch übrigens alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Ich stehe jetzt hier schon am Herd, habe hier meine große beschichtete Pfanne
und gebe da zuallererst Zucker rein, zusammen mit Wasser.
Und das Ganze dauert jetzt ungefähr 15min, denn wir lassen es karamellisieren.
Ich benutze dafür Stufe 7 von 9.
Ich habe auch zwischendurch den Herd nochmal runtergeschaltet.
Sobald nämlich eure Pfanne auf Temperatur ist, müsst ihr ein bisschen aufpassen.
Es kann nämlich sein, dass euer Karamell bitter wird weil es verbrennt und das wollen wir unbedingt vermeiden.
Ich gebe an der Stelle - Jetzt habe ich den Herd nämlich grad ausgeschaltet damit's nicht zu warm wird -
Ich gebe an der Stelle jetzt Butter rein, das schäumt dann ein bisschen
und anschließend lauwarme Sahne.
Bei der Sahne hat man erst das Gefühl, es verbindet sich nie
weil die Sahne erst mal richtig fest wird in der Karamellsoße und dann einfach immer weiterrühren,
notfalls nochmal ein bisschen erwärmen und dann funktioniert's auch garantiert.
Jetzt kommt die allerwichtigste Zutat: Salz.
Davon ordentlich reingeben, soll ja auch schließlich Salted Caramel werden.
Und dann das Ganze nochmal verrühren, abfüllen und kalt werden lassen.
Während des Erkaltens wird's dann auch nochmal ein bisschen fester.
Jetzt machen wir die leckere Creme und dafür habe ich hier Mascarpone.
Da gebe ich gleich ein bisschen Puderzucker rein und Milch für die Konsistenz.
Und die wichtigste Zutat ist hier das Magnum Eis.
Das mache ich so, dass ich mir das einmal in der Hälfte durchschneide.
Ich möchte nämlich die eine Hälfte als Deko on top legen
und die Hälfte gebe ich nochmal als Geschmacksträger in  die Creme.
Und fertig ist das wohl luxuriöseste Schichtdessert ever!
Ich kann euch nur sagen: Es schmeckt super gut!
Falls ihr kein Shortbread selber machen möchtet: *flüstert* Ihr dürft auch Gekauftes nehmen!
Aber selbst gemacht schmeckt's halt super, super frisch!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen und natürlich beim Probieren!
Falls ihr das neue Magnum Double Gold Caramel Billionaire auch schon probiert habt,
schreibt mir doch gerne mal in die Kommentare, wie ihr es findet und ob wir da den gleichen Geschmack haben.
Ich bin mir sicher ihr werdet es lieben!
Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag und sage: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!